Donald Trump's a longtime friend and
Republican strategist Roger stone was
mentioned 19 times in yesterday's
Intelligence Committee hearing the
committee's ranking Democrat congressman
Adam Schiff connected stone to the
alleged Russian hacker accused of
stealing email from the Democratic
National Committee and from Clinton
campaign chairman John Podesta in August
stones seemed to predict the revelation
of Podesta attacked emails tweeting that
it will soon be Podesta's time in the
barrel congressman Schiff asked FBI
director James Comey about it yesterday
do you know who Roger stone is generally
yes are you aware that he was a partner
Paul Manafort yeah mr. Schiff I'm wary
we're going to a place I don't want to
go which is commenting on any particular
person and so I don't think I should
comment do you know how mr. stone would
have known that mr. Podesta is emails
were going to be released it's not
something I can comment on director
Comey are you aware that Roger stone
played a role on the Trump campaign I'm
not gonna talk about any particular
person here today mr. Schiff Roger stone
is here for an interview you will see
only on CBS this morning Roger good
morning good morning have you talked to
the FBI
I have not air that you may be under
investigation well I have a assume that
because page one of the New York Times
on January 20th said that wiretap
information on Trump aids was being used
in an inquiry so I assume that I have
been under surveillance now for some
time what probable cause there is or
what evidence that would dictate that I
don't know they asked you one way or the
other not to destroy any document the US
Senate Intelligence Committee has sent
me a letter asking me to preserve
documents and I am doing so how do you
explain the fact that you said this
quote about John Podesta he was soon
going to be in a barrel because I wrote
an extensive investigative piece on John
Podesta the organized crime in Russia
and money laundering for the Clinton
Foundation which is what my reference
was to so were you surprised when John
Podesta Z mails came out as you seem to
predict ahead of time I was interested
like the rest of the country surprised
no I wouldn't say that I was surprised
there was an entire circle of Clinton
aides whose emails seem to get into the
into the mix here but the inference that
my now completely public exchange with a
hacker grew surfer 2.0 who may or may
not be a Russian agent somehow
constitutes collusion is not true based
either on the on the facts on the con
the actual text which I've released or
on the timing what are you talking to
Lucifer and Julian Assange first of all
I wrote along I wrote a long piece for
Breitbart news on Griffis crucifer and I
think you will see that my exchange with
him is entirely benign it is the only
exchange with him that I have had I've
made it public both the private tweets
and to end the direct messages Roger do
you see any hypocrisy here in terms of
the outrage that the team Trump is
feeling regarding leaks on possible
Russian collusion and the embrace of the
Trump by the Trump team of leaks that
damaged their opponent Hillary Clinton
what about the leaks in the New York
Times and elsewhere about Roger stone
those leaks if they are subject if the
surveillance of Roger stone and others
is because of a FISA warrant then the
leak of that information is a felony in
itself do you see anything that you've
know Donald Trump a long time both the
head of the FBI and the national
security adviser said yesterday that
it's not true that President Obama
wiretapped Donald Trump at Trump Tower
yet the White House is doubling down on
that saying there is still more to come
do you think now is the time given all
the information that we've seen for your
friend your longtime friend and your a
confidante to say listen I was wrong and
I'm sorry no actually I don't first of
all because the people he referring to
the same people who said there were
weapons of mass destruction and the and
Hussein had them who lied about
rendition who lied about torture and a
blue no no the FBI director he was not
involved never know what the
intelligence services the deep state as
a group do you so you think the
Americans should no longer trust the
recommendations and assessments of the
intelligence can
think that our intelligence community
has not been politicized would be naive
yet rectly then do you believe the FBI
you believe that trump tower was under
surveillance and was wire tapped I think
it is certainly possible and I think
we're going to find out Roger it's now
been revealed officially that you are an
under investigation for possibly
colluding with the Russians to meddle
with this election yes are you here to
say that you have had no contact with
Russians that you have not been involved
in trying to tamper with the elections I
have said that repeatedly and I say it
again today I believe that anybody on
Team Trump of the names that were
released yesterday Paul Manafort Michael
Flynn do you believe that any of them
had anything to do well obviously Paul
Manafort has been a friend of mine for a
long time and usher in my wedding he
denies it and if where I choose to
believe him I don't know general Flynn
but I would give him the benefit the
doubt Carter page never heard of this
guy don't know it so when people say
where there's smoke there's fire in this
particular case you say what let me have
my day in court
Roger stone thank you good to be here